foreign
podcast where we discuss what it means
to live a meaningful life with less my
name is Joshua Fields Milburn and I'm
Ryan Nicodemus and together we're the
minimalists we're here with malabama hi
everybody TK Coleman it's a beautiful
day oh man we've got a special guest for
you Julian Smith the author of The
Flinch is joining us here in a moment
we've got the rest of our team here in
the studio as well and coming up today
on this free public minimal episode
we're talking to a listener about the
fear of Letting Go we also have another
listener who is perpetually dissatisfied
with her career and has fear of career
consumerism we're going to talk about
the different ways that we Flinch in our
own lives then we've got a lightning
round question for you a live stream
question a listener tip and so much more
you can check out the full two hour
maximal edition of episode 392 where we
answer five times the questions and we
dive deep into several simple living
things segments that private podcast
episode is out right now at patreon.com
the minimalists your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free because
advertisements suck let's start with our
callers if you have a question or a
comment for our show give us a call
406-219-7839 or email a voice memo a
voice recording straight from your phone
to podcast at the minimalists.com our
first question today is from Betsy
hi this is
satara calling from health
trying to tame consumeristic Tendencies
is hard but something that we can work
on developing but what really is
challenging for me is the idea of
purging what is already present in our
lives I don't know that it's so much
that the sentimental value that things
hold but realizing that most things will
have absolutely no value in other
people's lives
um you know like sorting through parents
basements and closets and finding
knickknacks old sporting trophies tables
all these all this junk basically
um and can we really justify a
minimalist lifestyle uh when we know all
these things will just end up in the
dump because we they're you know made of
materials that can be recycled or
repurposed
um but how do we justify freeing
ourselves from all this extra weight of
material stuff in our lives which don't
add any value
but basically just dumping them
elsewhere to be someone else's problem
so joining us in the studio right now to
help us answer this question and a bunch
more questions is our good friend Julian
Smith he has a new book out it's called
the Flinch I say new because it's new in
print but this book came out like a
decade ago and it was really influential
and for me and also a lot of people in
our audience we've known Julian since I
think 2010 2011 yeah time frame when he
was writing a really popular blog and
I've always said about Julian he was the
guy who sometimes you go to someone for
some sort of advice or some insight some
observations and they'll sort of pet
your head and calm you down that's not
Julian Smith Julian Smith is the guy who
picks you up shakes the hell out of you
and then sets you down and you thank him
for it it's a rare talent that you have
yeah and this book is an astonishing
book and I thought this was a great way
to start this episode was with Betsy's
question because she's talking about the
fear of letting go now for me the fear
of clinging has become scarier than the
fear of letting go but it takes a bit of
time to get there and when I was
re-reading the Flinch I think I've
probably read this book four times now
and it's super insightful it's almost
like you wrote it one tweet at a time
because each each paragraph is
essentially quotable but there were two
quotes from the book that stood out for
Betsy's question I'd love to hear your
input on these the first one is the
strength you gain by letting go is more
important than any object you own wow
I um
I think
Betsy thank you thank you for calling in
and asking the question uh I've been to
Halifax many times I'm Canadian it's
really far to drive there from Quebec
where I come from because the road is
really windy uh but it's really worth it
and so I really appreciate you calling
him I the
it's it's so it's it's strange uh
because I feel I feel what you feel and
I feel it in your voice when you're
talking about it uh and I can I can feel
the
the worry that I think that I feel in in
your voice I think I hear it and and the
concern that someone might not
appreciate something the way that you
appreciate a I'm not sure if they
actually answer the question practically
or philosophically
um practically speaking
it's really easy object after object I
learned this from my fiance to uh to
take a photo of anything that you might
value and then to to discard the object
and then to be able to look at the photo
the same way that you would might look
at the object right that's some like
practical like and a simple thing to do
philosophically
uh to have so many uh different things
and to have them be memories
and to be able to look at something and
treasure the memory so I could see why
something like like that would provoke
someone to keep
thing after thing after thing after
thing I can see that and I feel that uh
and it resonates a lot with me
I it's uh
I I think to me the the way that I would
think to answer this in a way that I
would think to deal with it myself is is
I would look at this situation and I
would say well it's the memory that's
valuable it's not really the object
strictly speaking and the memory and
that emotion which is the emotion that
you feel in your voice and I could
actually I could hear a Betsy when I'm
when I'm listening to that message
uh that the actual memory and the actual
emotion is actually in you and not in
the thing right does that resonate with
you yeah absolutely yeah we often say
that our memories aren't in our things
they're inside us and last week we even
took it a step further we were talking
about sometimes we cling to these
memories that are actually cluttering
the present moment for us in a way I
thought about another passage from the
flinch
and and that passage you said you're
dropped into a forest alone at night can
you survive sure
do you stop caring about your 401k
definitely within 48 hours you're left
with the flinches that help you survive
and where Betsy is right now is she's
flinching at letting go of some things
that aren't actually going to harm her
in any way if she lets go of them
and part of the reason it's difficult to
let go is the story she's telling
herself that no one else will find Value
in these things and they're going to end
up in a landfill true some things might
end up in a landfill but you just said
many of them are recyclable or donatable
you can get rid of things without simply
trashing them but I love your
perspective here because you're dropped
into a forest alone at night Betsy you
stop worrying about letting go of the
things you instantly let go of them even
if they're still at your home but you've
let go of them mentally because they
don't matter in this moment yeah so that
that makes a lot of sense and and the
other side is
you know I I don't know I've come to
believe something uh over time that
people are past focused present focused
or future focused and typically it's a
state of mind and people will typically
stay in that mode
a lot right they'll be often past
focused and that'll be their traditional
way that they'll spend their time or
they'll be really future focused and
that'll be the majority of their
thinking will be future oriented and so
it's an opportunity in discarding the
past to embrace the potential future
which I think is uh you know it you know
that Napoleon Dynamite movie where the
guy is passing the football around to
himself and you like I forget the name
of the character uh but you you look at
these uh this this example this
stereotype of this person who is really
who believes that their best uh ears are
behind them yes and so so it's like
almost like the most uh the the more
stuff you have around you that reminds
you of your past the more you're like oh
those were the good days instead of the
good days are now or the good days are
coming yes right yeah and so we often
cling because we're clinging to the good
from the past we were talking about held
woodskin recently and he wrote the book
called The Sedona Method and one of the
things he talks about pride and pride is
often holding on to something because
you believe you can't replicate it again
right when I was seven years old I was
really proud when I tied my shoes but if
at 42 I was proud of tying my shoes
you'd look at me like I was insane right
because I got past that
yeah you know it's interesting how
sometimes we cling to things because we
fear other people won't appreciate them
like we did but part of having an impact
is you have to give up that right to
Define for other people how you're going
to impact them you give people a piece
of yourself in the form of Art in the
form of a story in the form of insight
and then they take that and they say oh
I'm going to use it to create this
result that matters to me and you don't
know what that is I think about the uh
the musician seal who said a fan came up
to him one time and says when you said
this lyric it changed my whole life and
he says I couldn't tell her that I never
wrote that lyric she missed her misheard
it but that's okay because she got what
she needed out of it right sometimes you
put things out there and people take
from it whatever they need and you gotta
let them run with it so will people
appreciate it like you no they're gonna
appreciate it very much unlike you but
that's part of the joy and possibility
of life you let something go you put it
out there and then people do some magic
with it and you say whoa I was able to
be a part of that that's pretty cool I
love they brought up Uncle Rico Julian
that's amazing from Napoleon Dynamite
all right yeah
I'm gonna see how many Napoleon Dynamite
references we can squeeze in here in
this podcast got a few yeah um Josh I
love that first quote that you you
talked about with uh uh quoting Julian's
book that I think a paraphrasing here
but it's what you gained from letting go
of a thing is is much more valuable than
the thing you're letting go of yeah so
that willingness to let go Betsy that is
a superpower and if you can get past
this fear
um you are like Julian says in his book
you're going to gain something so much
more valuable than worrying about those
trophies making it to the right home now
the one thing I will say is yeah like
some stuff is going to end up in a
landfill and that sucks but as soon as
you buy something as soon as you take
something into your home it's it's
already done the damage to the
environment so there is a proper way to
dispose of things but them sitting there
and decomposing in your house isn't any
different than if you gave it to a good
will and then they ended up throwing it
away or something like that but I'm
willing to bet Betsy that all of the
these things that you think kind of what
TK was saying that you think people
aren't going to get value from they
might get more value than what you're
assuming
um what the trophies thing specifically
I know there are like trophy companies
out there where they will take old
trophies and you can donate them and
they will use them and repurpose them
yeah and there's a lot of a lot of
different services that will repurpose
things that you never really thought of
so it might take a little bit of work it
it will take a lot of work but if you're
if you're willing to let go and if and
if getting that stuff out of your way is
going to help you live more in the
present then
um the work will be well worth it Betsy
one example with our guests
um someone asked Julian an interview I
don't even remember who it was but he
was like uh I think most people are just
gonna buy your book and leave it on a
shelf and they won't even apply it and
and Julian just had this attitude of
like you think I'm gonna let that stop
me from writing a book the fact that I
put it out there and some people don't
use it that would be silly right yeah
I've never seen Julian write a book or a
post about why you should blog every day
okay but he's the reason why I blog
every day because I read his blog it was
the first block I ever read long time
ago before anybody was blogging and he
was just writing about just taking risks
being authentic I remember him
referencing Ash amberjay him referencing
Seth Godin that's how I found out about
those people and like the power of
writing and I made a vow to myself I'm
like I'm gonna show up every day and
write a blog for a year most of my blogs
were crap but what that did for me in
terms of changing the way that I think
and the way that I process life was huge
he never put his blog out there with the
intent to get TK Coleman or anyone else
to blog every day but it had that impact
and he gets to say hey that's cool I
influenced something without having to
control it that's what you do when you
let things go without feeling the need
to tell other people how to appreciate
it
wow
it's High Praise Julian Smith it's uh
I'm just sitting here and just trying to
take it I want to give him more praise
but I don't want his head to get too big
but literally that's probably the book
that I recommend the most because it's
so digestible it's it's an easy read and
like Josh said one tweet at like every
single line is like a tweet thank you
that's excellent man Betsy I'm gonna
send you a copy of the Flint she'll put
a link to it in the show notes as well
Ryan what time is it you know what time
it is it's time for the lightning round
where we answer your questions from Tick
Tock yes indeed you can follow the
minimalists on Tick Tock Instagram
Facebook and Twitter at the minimalist
you can also follow Julian at Julian on
Twitter by the way Julian Smith joined
us on the private podcast for a bunch
more questions you're definitely going
to want to tune in to that patreon.com
the minimalist but now during the
lightning round this is where we answer
your answer your questions with a short
shareable less than 140 character
response we have 60 seconds to answer
your questions and we put those minimal
maxims in the show notes so you can copy
and share our pithy answers on social
media if you'd like you can find those
show notes at the minimalists.com
podcast from Alabama we got a question
here from decode life in practice fear
is difficult to eliminate how do we
handle the fears that come up in our
day-to-day lives well let's get 60
seconds on the clock for my good friend
Ryan Nicodemus oh you're going with the
pithiest of all the pithy answers to go
first huh pithy beam as we call him
oh that's so much better than the other
nicknames I got in high school all right
let's go 60 seconds uh my my pitified
answer is this courage does not exist
without fear so with this question it's
how do we handle the fears how do we
avoid the fears I don't think we avoid
fears I think we hit him head on I mean
obviously we want to be cautious we want
to do what we can to minimize as as much
damage as possible however you cannot
get rid of fears in life and if you want
to be a courageous person you will have
to hit those fears head on
that's spot on man yeah nice facing the
fear is what's important it's not
important to hide the fear or eliminate
the fear pretend the fear doesn't exist
that's right but actually facing it TK
Coleman we got 60 seconds for you what
do you got for us all right man let me
actually take 60 seconds which is
already started you don't have to be
Fearless in order to fear less the way
to overcome fear isn't by trying to dupe
yourself into believing that you need to
become some emotionally detached
automaton the way you deal with fear is
by being present to it allowing that
fear to be your teacher naming it
calling it out for what it is and then
asking yourself what must I do in spite
of the fear and then taking what you
must do and breaking it down boiling it
down until you can start so small that
it's easy to muster the courage to start
because you don't need the courage to
finish you just need the courage to get
going and once you get going the
momentum will take you where you need to
be your fillings are not there to be
overcome they're there to be engaged
with Consciousness with compassion and
with Clarity and when you do that you're
free whether you feel fear from time to
time or not
um I like to have pin that because I
think that is spot on but I want to help
decode life understand something that I
have finally begun to understand about
fear myself and it is this
every fear is a byproduct of
expectations
there are two types of fears there are
the rational fears that point us toward
danger if I do that I'm going to get
hurt I'm going to get mangled I'm going
to get trampled I'm going to end my life
and that's not what I want that fear is
rational okay pay attention to that fear
because it points toward danger
unfortunately most of our fears point us
in this other direction they make us
afraid to take any action at all I'm
afraid of being embarrassed I'm afraid
of what other people might think of me I
am afraid of offending someone with
something that I think is right
and when we experience that kind of fear
and we shut down when we Flinch from
that kind of fear it prevents us from
moving forward at all and so one fear
points us toward danger yeah that's
useful the other fear it's clutter it's
just in the way
let's check in with our patreon live
stream here in a moment but real quick
first for right here right now here's
one thing that's going on in the life of
the minimalist we announced this last
week but I can't wait to share it with
you I'd love to hear Ryan and TK
pontificate about it a bit as well
but the first time in almost 13 years
we're launching our own course we've
never taken the time to do this and my
God how much time did we spend on this
we've been working on it since last year
by the way and we're finally ready with
it we've spent hundreds of man-hours and
woman hours in Alabama
uh hundreds of hours
filming the course writing the course
trying to configure the course reworking
the course refilming the course
there's a lot of refilming of the course
oh man because we wanted to get it right
we wanted to add value create something
that stood the test of time it's called
simplify everything and it launches on
May 29th it's five weeks now it's 72
hours only you can sign up for so make
sure you're on the mailing list over
there at simplify everything dot XYZ
not.com simplify everything dot XYZ it's
five weeks it's 17 video lessons in each
lesson we tackle three different clutter
problem areas each week we tackle a new
form of clutter it starts with the
physical clutter the stuff but then we
move on to digital clutter and calendar
clutter and financial clutter and
relationship clutter identifying all of
these different problem areas that we've
heard from thousands of people and what
they experience we've been able to
distill your experiences down to a dozen
or so years of experience helping people
let go of the excess that's in their
life there's a 135 different
decluttering solutions throughout this
course a 30 page workbook student forums
and much much more to help you let go
but what was your experience of
filming the course preparing for the
course and helping people understand
that clutter goes Way Beyond the stuff
yeah for me it was a very symbolic
experience because it represents what I
consider to be the the dawning of a new
era in minimalism I think you guys have
been laying the foundation for the past
12 years and you've talked about it
you've mentioned it on a number of
different occasions but I think the
philosophy has evolved and people are
really ripe and ready for it for an
understanding of minimalism that says
this is not just a philosophy of Design
This is not just about the colors that
you wear this is not just about the
amount of things that you own it's about
Simplicity in every area of life it's
about clearing away all the Clutter
regardless of the labels and categories
we apply to it and so for us to really
unpack that in a dedicated way not just
an episode not just the rip here or
there I thought that was really exciting
and I just can't wait to see what this
course does for people and the feedback
that we start getting from people we're
not just going to give you the ABCs of
Simplicity we're going to give you the
xyz's because we're going to help you
get some closure in areas of your life
that have been previously unsettled at
simplify everything.xyz
[Laughter]
man I mean as far as um listeners
readers audience goes I'm really excited
because I think we've done a really good
job of um kind of touching these
different areas touching on these
different areas in a way that really
anyone can find Value on and I'm really
excited to see if people find Value in
it the way that I think they're going to
find Value on it because honestly if
this goes well I would love to do more
of these like this is a it's an amazing
experience I love loved working on this
project with you gentlemen
um I did learn that TK is the Kobe
Bryant of pontification
um I mean like we showed up the first
day to film so just give you a little
backstory we show up the first day to
film and I'm looking at all the things
we're going to talk about and as I'm
looking at it and preparing for it I'm
like oh yeah I talk about this all the
time talk about that all the time talk
about this all the time not going to be
a problem so I didn't really prepare too
much because I felt like I've been
preparing for the last 12 years to film
this course talking to you Josh is so
much different than talking to a camera
like looking at the camera like
instantly my heart starts to like write
starts to go up like 50
um so yeah it was a little bit of a
learning curve um it took me a while to
find the groove and figure out exactly
how much preparation I needed to do but
all that to say is all three of us went
way out of our way to make this the best
course possible for all of you and it
starts with the stuff and I think that's
important minimalism I don't want to
skip past the stuff yeah because I think
what we talk about there with the stuff
week when we the very first week it is
that physical manifestation of what's
going on inside you so before we tackle
the internal clutter of the relationship
clutter of the mental clutter the
calendar clutter we do want to clear the
excess around us because what does that
to do it makes room to start tackling
all of these other forms of clutter
throughout the course set the door to a
house yeah you got to go through that
door man yeah yeah simplify
everything.xyz put your email in there
we'll never send you spam junk or
advertisements but we will let you know
when the course is available it launches
May 29th 72 hours only let's check back
in with the patreon live stream Alabama
got a question for us I sure do this
question comes from Adam he says I may
be obsessed with personal development
I'm constantly trying to learn grow and
improve I love the feeling of leveling
up I know jfm has an aversion to better
but is there a healthy Improvement
you know I love this question Adam
because it's a misunderstanding of what
I'm saying and I want to clarify for
everyone I think it's okay to get better
it's okay to improve and the healthy way
it's another way of saying is there a
good way to but betterment or
Improvement is a byproduct it is not the
goal in and of itself for me and I want
to be clear about that yes I've become a
much better podcaster over the last
eight years a much better writer over
the last 20 something years I've become
a much better public speaker over the
last 30 years right or 20 something
years and I have done so not to get
better but immersing myself in something
that is compelling to me makes me better
improves me just by default yeah I think
for some people self-help is just
another manifestation of self-hate
instead of reading books and taking
courses from a place of already existing
self-affirmation from a sense of hey I'm
already enough I'm already worthy I
already love and respect myself but I'm
going to read something to pick up some
tools as part of this adventurous
process to learn how to express who I am
more authentically for some people it's
more like oh hey myself and here's just
more evidence for why I'm hateable and
there's this constant obsession with
maybe the next book will set me free
maybe the next course will make me
worthy of love maybe I'll finally be
happy if I buy one more self-help
motivational whatever it may be and so
if you're pursuing self-help in that way
then it's going to be unhealthy at the
same time for some people it might be
like dancing or playing basketball
people on the outside might say I don't
see how you can spend all those hours
doing that but if you're feeling joy in
the process then it works for you I know
for me if they came out with some study
that said hey new study shows that
reading self-help books actually makes
you less healthier I will be in trouble
I would be in big trouble because I
wouldn't be able to stop reading them
not because they make me better but I
just enjoy listening to smart people say
interesting things about life I I can't
not do philosophy I can't not learn from
other people I don't even know what that
looks or sounds like I don't want to
know and so if you can do something with
that kind of Joy which is what dancers
do musicians do artists do with what
they do then it becomes a kind of art
um there's got to be Tick Tock in there
somewhere that was good it's gonna be a
tick tock
man you know watching Josh uh go down
the road it's not self-help um but going
down the road of of of expounding uh
perspective on things and TK watching
how you do it what I see is two men
really trying to get a deeper level of
understanding yes and like that is I
think always going to be beneficial
because when you have a deep deeper
level of understanding hey you can make
more deliberate decisions and when the
discomfort and when the uncomfortable
things come up and the Flinch comes up
you're able to
um hold uh space for that in a way that
maybe you weren't to before you weren't
able to before because now you have a
deeper level of understanding about
those different emotions so to answer
your your question head-on uh self-help
to better yourself to constantly feel
like you need to level up
I agree it could be a it could be
something that actually holds you back
and leaves you with a feeling of being
incomplete but approaching it in a way
of having a deeper level of
understanding I don't think you could
ever go wrong with that context yeah and
quite often that desire to get help from
the self-help book or the course
whatever it might be can actually get in
the way I think it's going to make me a
better version of me
and the thing that we try to convey with
the minimalists and everything that we
do is that better version of you is
often found not by addition but through
subtraction you've already added all the
stuff to make me better
and it didn't work the way that I wanted
it to work and so right now it's like
let me get rid of this let me get rid of
this let me get rid of this what are we
doing you're uncovering yourself you're
understanding yourself better Professor
Sean just ran into this recently he
tracks all the books that he reads and
he's a fervent reader and yet recently
he's decided like hey this tracking of
everything I'm reading and making the
notes is actually making a little bit
less fun is that right
yeah I think so I just put my pressure
on myself to
choose what I was reading based on what
was going to help me finish more you
know I started reading this book a few
months ago and quit halfway through
because I wasn't really feeling it but
if I pick it up right now I only have
100 pages left that's another book I can
I can Mark as having red which makes me
a better person and now you have to slog
through it even though you're not
enjoying it but if I read enough then I
will be better well okay let's say
you're better but you're miserable that
you make yourself better at all right I
had a similar problem Professor with
note taking
I used to love just documenting what I
was reading not merely in terms of a
checklist but you know taking notes from
the books writing my Reflections and at
one time they were very valuable to my
students I was leaving leaving behind
this Rabbit Trail and I could see it
having a positive impact and people
finding it interesting but it got to the
point where I started to pick books
based on what would be easier to take
notes for I started to feel unhappy
about how slow I was going because it's
like all right instead of reading for an
hour that day I'm reading for like 15
minutes because I need time for
note-taking and I just got to a point
where I said you know what this ain't
the goal man maybe I'll come back to
this if an easier more aligned way
emerges but I'm just going to go back to
enjoying what I do and just reading and
I've been having fun ever since yeah
yeah so yeah if there isn't joy in the
Improvement or joy and the betterment
then you're not actually getting any
better you're just dragging yourself
through the mud for no reason at all
just to show that look how dirty I can
get yeah yeah I mean I think about like
Sean in his example where Maybe
there was a point in time where he was
like I really want to have a deeper
level of understanding I want to expand
my knowledge I want to be able to speak
um you know intellectually to these
different topics so that was his goal
and keeping track of all the books
helped him get there but now we can see
how smart Professor Sean is with or
without his list and he's at that point
where like that list doesn't surf him
anymore so kudos to you man for
recognizing that that's awesome yeah
Bravo
well Ben we're gonna check back in with
the live stream here in a bit but in the
meantime what do you got for us here's a
minimalist Insight from one of our
listeners
hi Josh and Ryan my name is Sandra and
I'm from Norway I would like to share a
quote that changed my view on minimalism
I've been on this journey for about
seven years now and this month I have
been doing my version on the minimalism
game where I try to let go of 500 items
in total my boyfriend saw a pair of
shoes I was going to sell and said that
they were nice shoes I told them I
agreed but that I did not wear them and
that they did not add value to my life
anymore he then said this just because
something is pretty doesn't mean you
have to own it alright y'all that's our
minimal episode for today we'll see you
on patreon for the full two hour maximal
edition of episode 392 which includes
answers to a bunch more questions like I
want to get rid of this one thing but
what if I need it in the future what
happens if you get rid of 50 of your
clothes today what would happen
what's my identity if I get rid of all
the things that make me who I am plus a
million more questions for Julian Smith
and the minimalists also this week we
have a private minimalist home tour from
one of our listeners who shows us that a
minimalist space doesn't need to be
sparse or sterile
all that and much much much more of less
and if you want to hear all that check
out the minimalist private podcast at
patreon.com the minimalist or click the
link in the description to subscribe and
get your personal link so that our
weekly maximal episodes play in your
favorite podcast app you also gain
access to all of our archives all the
way back to episode zero zero one and if
you're still on the fence here's a
testimonial from one of our lovely
patreon supporters anima says even
though I pay for your private podcast
what you say is priceless because it is
full of genuine heart and wisdom I think
she's talking about TK right definitely
she says I'm so grateful to be part of
this private Community the most recent
episode and many others have added
tremendous value to my life Wow thank
you so much anema we appreciate that and
we appreciate Julian Smith for joining
us today you can check out his book it's
called the Flinch we'll put a link to
that in the show notes as well and if
you leave here today with just one
message
rather be this
love people
and use things because the opposite
never works
thanks for listening y'all see you next
time peace
every little thing you think that you
need
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed or I bet that you'll
be fine without it thank you foreign
every little